hi all uh welcome to jio special data
analysis talk and
the speaker history is a co-founder of
where Robert Inc Adventure back company
for helping businesses to drive inside
from special special temporal data and
leads the engineering team at rare
robots please welcome him
[Applause]
uh
all right
okay folks uh can you guys hear me from
back
okay nice nice
all right folks welcome to my talk today
so the title I'm gonna talk today is
drill Unleashed how Apparition is
revolutionizing geospatial data analysis
so my name is yeah so before we get
started let me just introduce a little
bit about me so I'm the co-founder at
our variable sync so variables is a
cloud database platform for geospatial
analytics and Ai and by the way we are
hiring
so I'm also the VP and the PMC chair or
a party Sedona so Sedona is a top level
project at Apache software Foundation
and I was a computer science professor
at Washington State University before so
I never here actually graduated from WSU
okay no I I saw there will be someone
from WSU all right anyway so my research
before was focused on distributed job
special dbms database Management Systems
also database indexing as well as Joe
special data visualization so I got my
computer science PhD from Arizona State
and I also spent time at Apple Microsoft
research as well as IBM research
okay now let's get started So today
we're going to talk about data
in particular geospatial data
so as per Azure so approximately 80
percent of an organization's data has a
location component or geospatial
component of spatial temporal component
whatever called right so I believe you
guys here you know you guys from many
different companies
and you have lots of data in your daily
daily life right so you'll probably do
uh dealing real didn't even realize that
so the data you are using on a daily
basis actually have a location component
yet
so this is just because so there are a
couple challenges for geospatial data
so there right now there are two
challenges for when people use or deal
with geospatial data so the first
challenge is people always underestimate
the values of geospatial data so you
have lots of data but you don't know you
should put it in the right context you
should relate it to space and time so
you can drive more values from your
geospatial data
the second challenge is
even if you know you have lots of Juice
by your data you want to make sense of
this you want to get the most out of it
however due to the massive scale of Joe
special data you don't have efficient
tools or scalable tools to help you
analyze and process the big geospatial
data so today we're going to talk about
the how we can address the first two
challenges
so first
if you want to make sense out of your
data or your geospatial data you'll
first need to relate your data to space
and time so if you do so you can
actually tell real world quantity story
about your data set use space and time
so for example suppose you have a
database in your company and you look at
your database there is a transaction
seeing that a customer bought a coffee
if you just look at this information you
cannot get much out of it it doesn't
tell you much right but
if you're related to space and time
so a customer bought a coffee at the
Starbucks store at intersection I-90 and
i-445 on Monday at 7 am so this opens up
a whole new different world for you
so you can do lots of things on it you
can do Superior temporal analysis
hotspot analysis
traffic analysis lots of different
things you can do on the geospatial data
so given that you probably realize so
there are lots of juice build it and it
is actually very useful
in fact so here comes the geospatial
data Universe in fact lots of data you
are using that I trick can be considered
as geospatial data for example Telemetry
data so the GPS device is installed on
your fleece install your mobile devices
also use network data also satellite
images
so this actually is a very large set of
Telecom data right traffic data
residential Maps as well as medical
services so your packages right so how
you're going to help how the drivers
deliver your packages to different
locations so what are the Deliverance
centers what are locations right so all
this data can be considered as
geospatial data as well as the natural
disasters right so the storms so where
so when the storm will come so where the
storm will go right where are the fares
so all this data all this natural
disaster data there are also geospatial
data
so
as you see you can get lots of your
special data from many different data
source
so now you want to make sense of this
data right however the problem is this
data are very huge
why so
so
the data you collect from your vehicles
from your mobile devices from your
tightly container sources so there are a
lot
so nowadays we have over 5 billion
mobile devices all around the world so
they keep generating
GPS information through the sensors
upload it to your servers they're just
huge
also the dual network data so the Dual
segments the streets the addresses right
so for example open street map so which
is the data source that is the backbone
of the the modern map services so open
so Google Maps Apple Maps they're all
using some sort of information from
openstreetmap so openstreetmap has over
one terabyte little network data and not
only that so osm data gets updated on a
daily basis just imagine that it is
just very hard to to process right
also satellite images
the geo special images you collect from
satellite you collect from your drones
right so all this data
also huge
so for example NASA you know they have a
couple of satellites running outside the
world and monitoring the monitoring the
status of the inter planning 24x7 right
so NASA has over 22 petabyte satellite
imagery data
so this is possibly already beyond your
imagination right so given this huge
amount of geospatial data how can we
find a scalable and efficient tool to
process and analyze data
so Here Comes Here Comes Apache donut
so what age are paracetona a particular
is an open source cluster Computing
engine for processing large-scale
geospatial data
so I posted Three Links here so you can
check check our website which is
sedona.apache.org
and our GitHub is Apache is a donor
under the Apache organization
we also we also have Twitter account at
Apache Sedona so if you're interested
you can follow us to get the latest
updates
now let me quickly go through the
current status of a purchased donor so
the figure on your the figure on your
right is the current contributors and
users of a Paris Sedona as you'll see
they're from many different companies so
Amazon databricks uh JB Hunt
Mercedes-Benz T-Mobile Uber so lots of
big companies are using Sedona to make
sense of their geospatial data in
production
so
I am the original creator of apartheid
owner so
we started this project as a as a
research project on my PhD study so in
2015 so Sedona becomes mature in 2017.
so back then it was called geospark
so Sedona joined Apache software
foundation in 2020.
and so now it has over 10 000 corporate
users
it has 98 contributors on GitHub
it has over 1. 1.4 000 stars on GitHub
last month
it had over 1 million downloads overall
our total downloads have have exceed 13
million
also
the the python binding of a paraced
owner is ranked among top one percent
most downloaded packages on pipei
okay now let me quickly go through the
architecture
of a party Sedona
so upper Sedona as a computation layer
in the middle
so on top of a pressure donor you can
connect to many different developer
tools for example Apache exactly
a tableau Jupiter notebook dual pandas
are Studio
and underneath a partisan owner it can
run on top of many different distributed
computation engine a party spark a
project link and we're going to support
snowflake very soon
so Sedona also support many different
data formats spatial data formats
geojson
parquet Geo parquet wktwkb geotif so on
so forth also you can run Sedona on
different public Cloud vendors AWS
databricks Azure Google Cloud so and so
forth
so
in inside Apache set owner so we have
this layer called spatial query
processing layer
so first it provides interface program
interface to the end user it provides
special SQL interface python Scala Java
and R intervention
it equips with a number of different
distributed spatial query algorithm also
it has special credit optimizer
to help you find the best algorithm
given the given the statistics of the
input data set
so special card processing layer is
built on top houses distributes spatial
data set layer
so inside our spatial data set layer we
have spatial partitioning spatial
indexing and also spatial data
compression
so this distribute special data set
layer as I mentioned before is built on
top of distributed computation engine
such as Apache spark for batch
processing such as Apache fling for
stream processing also snowflake
okay so given this architecture
let's take a look at a few examples
about how companies run queries in
particular spatial SQL in a paraceted
so first of all I want to ask you guys
who often I know you know SQL
just raise your hand
yeah a lot almost everybody knows SQL
right so this is like a standard has
been out there for for like four decades
or something right so spatial SQL
probably never heard of it I'll never
use it before but spatial SQL is also a
standard so it is standard has been out
there probably three decades or two
decades or something okay so there are
lots of systems spatial database
implementing this standard to help users
make sense of their data
so what is that how can you use it so
let's look at this example
now suppose we have a table so this
table is called New York City Taxi trip
records so it has the following
information
so each row each row in this tape in
this table is a trip record it's a taxi
trip record it has a license plate
timestamp
pickup Point drop off point trip Fair
trip distance
so basically the information our taxi
trip now we also have a credit window
a polygon which indicates like this one
which indicates the boundary of the
Manhattan region
now
I have a special query
so I want to know what other trips
started in Manhattan
right so if you visualize this query on
map
which is the map on your right
so so this Square window is just the red
rectangle on the map so we want to
return all the taxi taxi trip records
that started within this red color
rectangle
so if we write a spatial SQL
the query will be like this one
select from here so these are just
standard uh standard SQL syntax right
now the difference is
so for spatial data now we have one more
spatial predicate called St contains
called SD continues so the SD continues
take two inputs in this example so the
first input is the polygon the polygon
the boundary of the Manhattan region
right so the second input is the taxi
pickup points so it is a column name in
the text trip records table
so Sedona gonna take this special query
and execute Leverage The Power of the
distributed engine
and then return user points database in
this car window okay so this query is
very simple but very common special
special query so it is called spatial
range query
special Branch power so what you give
here is a wrench car window a polygon
okay
now here is a more challenging query
suppose we have two tables right table
one is a city table table two is a
driver table
so let's say the table it is very simple
it contains all the information our city
so for example we have Seattle we have
Bellevue we have Redmond so we have a
geometry column this German column
describes the spatial boundary of each
City
so in your driver table we have three
columns the name Ultra driver and the
location which is the geometry column
the location of each driver
so we have two tables now the question
I'm going to ask is
so I want to find drivers in each
setting
okay so how can we drive this query
using spatial SQL
here you go
so still the syntax is Select from there
right
so in the from class it actually
involves two tables City table and the
driver table and in the mirror class it
still use St contains as the credit
predicate so the difference is now this
acid contains take two in two columns as
input
so
the boundary of the settings and the
locations of the drivers
so this query
is called
it is called spatial joint query it
involves two tables
and we're going to join these two tables
based on their spatial spatial property
okay
now we know this is a special query but
the question is
this query is actually very challenging
why
in terms of time complexity
okay just think about that you're
drawing these two table together suppose
if if you don't have any optimized
special algorithm so what is time
complexity
it is unscripted right it is unscript it
is very slow especially when it comes to
Big Data big geosparated especially when
it comes to joining a computer cluster
just will not work okay
so in Sedona what we did is so we
designed very highly optimized spatial
joint algorithm to optimize this
particular query so it can see
and he's no longer in square it is very
fast it also leveraged our spatial index
techniques so I won't get into details
of this art algorithm today but just
leave the question for you and I will
give you some hints later on
okay now
let's look at another query
so this query is called I want to find
my neighbor my nearest neighbors right
suppose we have a table like this one we
call the restaurant table
so what it has is the restaurant name
right it also has location on each
restaurant
so this is since this kind of scenario
is very common in you know food food
delivery company or Yelp this kind of
food recommendation company right now I
want to ask one question
so please tell me the nearest 20
restaurant
and the screenshots on your right is
actually a real screenshot I took from
my Yelp app right so this is a very
common query so you want to return the
top key nearest neighbor
so how can we do that in spatial SQL
so you can write a query like this one
and the cylinders query to Sedona so
what happens is in the select Cloud you
have this function called St contains
your calculated distance between the
restaurant and your own location right
and then you store the distance
ascendingly
and you take the top 20 right so this is
like I guess it is kind of very
straightforward right
but now
let me ask you another question so what
is the time complexity of this query
so
you probably think okay so you have like
other bag here so that requires sorting
right so according to our textbook
knowledge so sorting in the if you're
writing your own computer use a modern
sorting algorithm it is like on average
a login right
so
if we run this query run this query in
this way on a distributed cluster it
simply does not work it takes a lot of
time also it actually not needed
so in Sedona they actually also
Implement optimize algorithm for this
particular query so it's no longer a
login it runs super fast also leverage
our special partitioning leverage our
spatial indexing okay
so I will give you more details later on
so okay so a follow-up question a
follow-up slide
about the St distance function
so actually there is a problem of the St
distance function you probably don't
even realize
so how can we calculate the distance
between two point
so here are two points
0.00 and 0.11
so if you cut if you want to calculate
the distance between these two points
very straightforward just use your
euclidean distance right so it is square
root 2 O2 right
however
how about the geospatial locations
right
suppose we have two points like this one
right so minus 74 something and 40 blah
blah blah right so these are the special
points how can you calculate the
distance
between these two points
apparently apparently you cannot use
euclidean distance why first of all
so the the coordinates you see in this
in this formula it's actually longitude
and latitude
right so that degrees the unit of this
longitude and latitude are degrees right
apparently you cannot use your cleaning
distance
also even if you manage to use euclidean
distance to calculate the distance so
what is the unit what is unit of the
distance you get so kilometer or miles
so they are not they're not correct at
all
so in fact as you all know so Earth is a
sphere also it is not a perfect sphere
so how can we calculate the distance
between two geolocation
so in Sedona
we provide the function called St
transform
so what he does is it transform the the
coordinates from a degree based
coordinate reference system
to meter-based coordinated reference
system and after that you could use the
SD distance to calculate the distance
between two points and this distance
based on what you choose it could be
kilometer it could be Mouse but it is
something you can understand you can use
for other applications
so if we put this on visualization
basically we transform a degree based
coordinate reference system to a planner
space to to the coordinates on on our
map okay on the map you see there
all right
now
the data I have mentioned before in the
past few slides there are points polygon
this kind of thing right
how about Geo images
so this Geo images they're usually
called laser data so here is an example
so the image down there is actually a
it's a satellite image of the
interplanet you can get from NASA from
or from other
lenders right so this image contains
information on the entire planet it is
so huge so usually when people store it
people store it in small tails
Okay small image tail so each image tail
is probably a few kilobytes so you can
use a regular image viewer to open it
and view it
so how Sedona stores this kind of data
internally
so we store it in a table from it as you
see here so each row in this table
actually is a record our map tail
so it first has name for the tile name
it also has a column geometry which
indicates the spatial extent of this map
tail so which region this image tail
describes right
it also houses column which actually
store the data of this raster image tail
so it looks like this one we store it as
a 2d array
we also store the information of each
pixel each element in this 2D array
even that now let's look at the query
for lesser data
suppose we have the temperature the
global temperature information our 2015.
we also have the global temperature
information of 2014. now I want to
calculate the climate change between
this one year
in other words I want to calculate the
temperature difference between these two
big satellite images okay
so
logically
it should be very easy so all we need is
so we use the temperature in 2015 minus
temperature in 2014 and then we got the
difference
right so you can actually do this in a
Paris Sedona use two different queries
so the first query is this one
so of course this is still special SQL
query right select from here
so in this in the rear Clause you join
these two tables the temperature in 2015
and 14 by their tile name and then you
use this function called RS
a subtract so essentially what it does
is it subtracts value
or raster image T1 from raster image T2
okay
you can also join them together through
their spatial attribute right you can
join them by their uh spatial attribute
and use this predicate St equals so it's
simple to check whether it's the two
image whether the two special extent are
identical if they're identical so they
are considered as the same image
okay
all right so I have we have seen lots of
special queries in Paris Sedona right
now let's take a look at how Sedona
internally process these queries
so the special color processing layer in
Sedona has three major components
special Curry Pastor credit Optimizer
and the credit executor
so in the spiritual passer it can
actually pass pass different spatial
Expressions I still contains St distance
and the r is subtract right it also
introduced two spatial data tab first
the first one is geometry type
it includes Point polygon lens strings
this kind of thing multi-polygon so they
don't support many different geometry
types
also dresser tab for storing geometry
for storing the Geo image the raster
data right in the query Optimizer we
support spatial filter push down spatial
function folding spatial joint algorithm
planning so on so forth
and in the special career executor they
support distributed spatial index uh
distributed spatial data compression
which is spatial serialization and
cellulite digitalizer
okay
now I'm go I'm also we don't have enough
time I'm gonna quickly go through a few
key optimization we introduced in a
parasite donut
so the first thing is called geospatial
Data partitioning
so data partitioning is a critical
factor in a distributed system
it will significant affect the current
query performance in a distributed
system so what it means is that give a
huge data set you need to chop the data
set to small partitions and you need to
send these partitions to different
machines that way you can parallel the
current workload so each machine can
take a piece of data and work on it
right
we introduce this thing called steel
special data partitioning the idea
behind it is we want to partition the
geospatial data based on their spatial
proximity
but we also want to achieve load balance
so what does that mean
so it means that we want to partition so
it means that the nearby objects nearby
geospatial objects going to be put in
the same partition and also each
partition should have similar size so
that way each machine in the cluster can
get a
who can get a fair share right can get a
similar workload
so if you look at this partition
Technique we introduced in Sedona
so with Partition data
by their special proximity and if there
if there is a region has lost hospital
records it is super dense so you're
going to have smaller partition
a smaller box to partition data
so this is how we patching data in
Sedona
alternatively in Sedona we also provide
two other functions two other way to
help you to partition data so one is
Google S2 partition method another one
is Uber H3 partition method although we
don't recommend that because they don't
have good they don't have good
performance and our our optimized
special drawing algorithm are much
faster than this
now
I'm going to leave two questions for you
so first how to get this grid file now
we know the idea right but how can we
actually give a special data set how can
we derive this grid field to partition
data right so that's the first question
although I don't have to get I don't
have time to get into that but I won't
just want to give you some uh question
the second question is
how about polygons
so the data you see here right now
they're all points right you can easily
partition Point put the point to
different partitions right but what
about the polygons what if there are
some polygons sit on the boundary
without a boundary of two partitions
how can you partition it how can I send
it to different which partition you it
should go right
so this is a question for you
so since I don't know we have all this
kind of augmentation technique to handle
all these kind of cases
another Technique we introduced in
Sedona is the geospatial index in
particular distribute special index
so instead distributed cluster we have
the Master machine which is a purple one
we also have a number of worker machine
so the spiritual index outside owner
exist
on every single machine so we build a
small special index on each worker
machine of this cluster so this small
local index could be archery or quad
tree but they are very small size they
only index the data of its local
partition
another important feature we introduced
recently into a paraceted owner actually
but in a Paris I don't know 1.4
we just released it a few months ago
so it is geopar K radiant writer support
so I believe most of you here probably
already heard of parquet format before
but if you don't know it
so here is a quick introduction so
parquet format is a hybrid format that
combines both low store and column store
so basically what it means is that so
given given a big data data set it first
partition data partition data by rows
okay for example the first 100 rows go
to partition the second 100 rows go to
Second partition so on so forth you
partition the data based on rows so
inside each partition it organized data
using the column store format to speed
up the analytics applications
so basically it means you store data by
column so all data are one columns Stay
Together
so in addition to the format itself
parquet also introduced metadata in each
partition in each partition so this
metadata includes some
some concise index information such as
Mi Max information of each column so
this mean Max information going to help
you to prove some partitions
before you even load it into into the
main memory
is an extension is also standard it's an
extension two packet file so what it
does is it introduce the geometry type
and the geometry column for the packet
field
and not only that for the this geometry
column it also introduced this metadata
called bbox
so this big box store together with each
column also with each
each real group each partition it can
also help you to prune Data before you
actually load the entire data set
so the jio parquet format
become material later last year later
last year I Remember December December
something
so Sedona now supports geopar case
standard 1.0 beta 1.
so here is an example about how why you
should use this geopocket reader and
writer in a paraceton consider this
spatial SQL query so this is the special
range query you have seen before using
the New York City Taxi trip data right
so this is a special filter use St
contains so results package reader what
happens is so suppose your data is
stored in Amazon S3 right you're running
out your cluster your Sedona cluster
with spark on Amazon EMR on databricks
right you have to load the entire data
set from S3 into your cluster so this is
super slow right so we said on the Geo
parquet reader what happens that you're
going to only read the data that are
possibly related to this query into your
cluster into the memory of your cluster
so make sure it's super fast and reduce
the
the time you're spending on read the
data you spend on uh the data transfer
through the network right
Okay so another component another
component inside is the geospatial data
serializer
so I believe some of you probably have
heard of serializer or serialization
before socialization is a very typical
technique when people transfer data
through Network right so when you
transfer some your memory objects
through the network you're going to
serialize the data to a battery and on
the other side of the network you can
take the battery and reduce to recover
the original object
so first I don't know what we do is that
so we we serious geometry to battery and
later on
we digitalize the jumps back to
digitalized battery back to the geometry
so this is actually huge bottleneck
for
for geospatial data system right why
if you just think if you if your data
type is just integer string
double this kind of data format so this
won't be a bottleneck but for spatial
data imagine that you have seen polygons
polygon coordinates before right so the
polygon the spatial boundary of our
state our city they're just huge it's a
single polygon could contains thousands
of different corners if you don't have
an efficient sterilization mechanism it
will take lots of time for you to run
this query in a distributed environment
so without this
it currently could it could take up to
50 percent time
for regular special Curry I'm just
serializing and digitalizing data so you
waste lots of time
so instead owner we have efficient
serializer
in Sedona 1.0 to 1.3.1 so we use our
our own geometry sterilizer it's a
generated battery rate is three times
smaller than the curio serializer 20
times faster in terms of serialization
and five times faster in terms of
digitalization instead of 1.4 we
introduce a new set of serializer for
geometry type so it is up to five times
faster than our original geometry
sterilizer
so since we can get rid of lots of
overhead here
okay let me speed up a little bit
here is a quick performance Benchmark so
we use a down on spark and we compare it
with different competitors so the first
Benchmark is actually conducted in 2018
so at that time there are a few other uh
a few other spatial framework special
processing framework on top of spark so
we compare with them and this data set
we are running on is 1.3 billion New
York Taxi trip data set with 171
000 City boundaries running on four
machines
as you see many of them they run auto
memory and cannot even finish Sedona
finish the entire query
in less than 10 minutes
and the original spark took one day and
still not finished
we recently conduct another benchmark
so we run Sedona
on 80 billion osm notes which is around
1.7 terabyte and join it together is is
the same with the same city data set we
joined on 10 machines on EMR it takes
about five hours to finish
we also draw another data set which is
osm shows so this Rose is the road in
the United States or in the entire world
usually it is a long trajectory very
very long across many cities probably
across a couple States even
so we joined we use 7 72 million osm
shows joined with the city data set it
used three minutes to finish
we also compare Sedona with another
popular Library python Library called
geopenders it is single machine solution
and also help you to analyze geospatial
data so to be fair we run this query on
a single machine
so we run an application called spatial
aggregation
essentially what it does is it
Aggregates these aggregate spatial
records based on the location based on
sale ID
to find the Hotspot
so as you'll see here if you have a very
small data set so jio pandas is very
good here I'm not shooting down jio
panels I'm just saying when the data set
is large Japanese is just not performed
very well but if you have a small data
set you can go ahead and use dual
pendants so Sedona is a has similar
performance as opposed to Joe pandas
when the data set is relatively small
around you know 1.4 million but when the
data set becomes larger and larger jio
pandas soon
run out of memory Barcelona can still
finish the the query in about in this
case around
240 seconds
so Sedona in this case also leveraged
the multiple CPU cores on the machine on
a local machine
okay I'm gonna quickly go through a few
applications a real use use cases in
inside uh outside owner so we get all
these applications from the open source
community of Sedona
so IG so IH is an insurance company in
New Zealand and Australia area so they
use Sedona to analyze so which areas and
adults are the most disaster prone So
based on the result they can adjust
their insurance premium so they can
charge more higher price for you for
people who live in those areas right
to get to answer how traffic and
residential addresses change on a daily
basis since we can get a more accurate
results for their drivers to deliver the
packages for you
T-Mobile
T-Mobile use Sedona to answer how the
population density geographically
clustered
so this way they can decide whether they
need to build more you know seller
Towers in different areas right
also Mercedes-Benz so they use the donor
to answer which area has have more
traffic and more car accidents so that
way they can investigate the reason
behind it and also probably better
design their vehicles right
all right so
so Sedona can actually integrate with
many different tools as I mentioned
before so it can be integrated with
Apache example in a notebook environment
in this case you can run a special SQL
on the notebook and also draw charts
Maps use a donut
it can also integrate with python it can
seamlessly work with jio pandas shape
play so if you have jio pandas data
frame you can send it to you can convert
it to Sedona easily and if you have
Sedona data frame so you can also
convert it to geopen that's data frame
easily so this is this is seamless
integration
Sedona can also be integrated with
Jupiter notebooks so right now most of
our users actually are actually use uh
Sedona python-based Jupiter notebooks
so we also have a few demo notebooks so
use to use due to the time limit I won't
go through the notebooks here but I'm
going to share a slides with you guys
you know so you can join uh go back home
and drive so we host all the notebooks
on my Bender so you can open up and play
around with this I don't
okay so let me just stop here do you
have any questions
thank you
sure so was this gentleman ask is so as
I mentioned so say don't support drastic
data processing right so hit ask so do
we have any uh performance performance
Benchmark against these applications
so this is a very good question so right
now I don't have a number right now so
we are still developing more and more
functions for certain adjuster so we are
planning to run a new Benchmark very
soon probably in the next month to see
how Sedona drags your data processing uh
outperform other competitors
but thank you for this question
go ahead
I
that good but as old as
yeah got your point so
that's a very good question what is this
gentleman asks is so I mentioned this
Jose don't support can interact with
geopenness what he asked is so what do I
mean by this integration does that mean
so we can load pandas data into Sedona
and explore pandas data in improve
explorers data to geoplanets or we
support geopunters candlestel
programming still a programming API in
Sedona so the answer is so we actually
support both in the sense that so you
can you can of course load geopolis data
into Saturn and also export data to two
geoplanets on the other hand since since
the example
since the example we are given here so
they actually use salon on top of Apache
Spark so that means you know recently a
price box invest a lot on mimic the
pandas API in Empire spark right so that
means if you run Sedona on a pi spark if
you want to have some kind of panda
style API so we can still support that
but of course we don't have special
design on Sedona for to to to mimic the
geopolis API 100 on our platform
hope this answers your question
yes yes
hello okay uh so
time is I guess now it's like taking a
break and we have lightning talks at
four o'clock
so yeah
thank you